ja
[Musik]
ein wachstum hätte ich mir auch mit
emotionen verbunden die sich werden
[Musik]
diese arbeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gewählt ist mit 125 stimmen mein amt
widmer-schlumpf
sie muss sich ein quasi wenn sie zur
seite wenn ich sie in den augen vor
ferner wählerinnen und wähler fordert
eine verräterin
guten tag meine damen und herren wir
müssen uns bewusst sein dass frauen die
nacht macht und einfluss greifen
eine bedrohung darstellen für die macht
der männer
[Musik]
ich erkläre
vorm im bundesrat haben sie es schwerer
als männer
was machen sie anders
und
wie unterscheidet sich ihre politik von
derjenigen ihrer kollegen
[Musik]
zu hause bei alt bundesrätin elisabeth
kopp
das macht spaß für sich allein getroffen
ich habe marco täterschaft auch gern
burggasse hat und durchkreuzt und danke
gesagt hat dann tut es gut geht und er
macht spaß
ihr mann hans jakob vor neun jahren ist
er gestorben
wir haben
sie verloren sich am selben tag mit ihm
wird sie hoch aufsteigen und später tief
fallen
[Applaus]
ich weiß noch gut an die schülerklasse b
zunahme erschwere futterbau kann ich mit
aktualisierter beziehung einfach gut
machen musste sich steiner werk aber
auch süchtig habe bewiesen dass wir nach
aussage der frau hat's nötig physisch
oder psychisch dem amt nicht gewachsen
dass ich kann ihnen aus naheliegenden
gründen nichts versprechen im bundesrat
meinen mann zu stellen was ich ihnen
jedoch zu sagen kann ist dass ich alles
tun werde um das was als frau und als
mensch in mir steckt aufzubieten
in diesem sinne erkläre ich annahme der
wahl
mit elisabeth kopp zieht 1984 erstmals
eine frau in den bundesrat
eine bürgerliche frau schafft was ein
jahr zuvor der kämpferischen
sozialdemokraten lilian uchtenhagen
verwehrt wurde
[Musik]
das geht mir nicht nur um grundsätze es
geht mir auch um gebäude die heute liebe
ich mache ich politik auf twitter diese
leute das so war herr stich ist gewählt
mit 124 stimmen
das ist sagt möchte das deutsche und das
die waren einen daumen schraffur ihre
übrigen hätte gerne frau aber nicht ihr
und dabei hat wohl höchste volumen der
säge war vermutet wird bald geschwister
oder eher darauf an hühner oder etwas
gibt das weiß ich nicht sie jetzt auch
sehr viel besser richter ich glaube sie
sind zehn monaten etwas zu töten und sie
sind einfach ob sie zum händler
hans gewalt
[Musik]
136 jahre lang regierten die männer
alleine 117 bundesräte kennt die schweiz
und nur sieben davon waren weiblich
[Applaus]
ruth dreifuss war die zweite vor zwei
wochen in genf
wir treffen sie in ihrer wohnung so
politisiert wurde wird sich einfach vom
in ihre verstecke familie geboren 1940
zweiter weltkrieg in einer jüdischen
familie eine twitter deutsch
österreichische grenze meint dass das
ist schon ein anfang sagt immer anfang
ihm bewusst sei was politik bewirkt
im märz 1993 übernimmt die frisch
gewählte sp bundesrätin dass
departements des innern
eigentlich hätte sie die
sozialdemokraten christian brunner
bundesrätin werden sollen
[Applaus]
doch das parlament wählt zuerst diesen
mann gewählt ist mit 130 stimmen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sp-nationalrat matte lehnt die wahl ab
die sp hält an christian brunner fest
und steht noch zusätzlich ruth dreifuss
vor dann plötzlich gerüchte christian
brunner habe für nacktfotos posiert
absolute hinter stammkeeper
männerfantasie pro dreyfus hat die
besseren chancen
ich fürchte dass es in zwei gründe sind
und weiter sind unannehmbar
ich glaube dass äußerliche vielleicht
ich beruhige die leute weil ich ein
wenig bieder aussehe
und das ist nur weil ich mich darum
nicht interessiere wie ich aussehe
und das zweite ist vielleicht weil ich
entspreche genau was man von einer frau
in der politik erwartet ledig keine
familie so etwas zwischen mann und frau
das alles geopfert hat und dadurch
vielleicht eine anspruch hatte auf
anerkennung und beides ist für mich sehr
schockierend
stimmen erhalten 112 86 der stimmen ihre
schopfe und und buch xs ist normaler
etwas mehr erwartet und noch herhahn
einfach mit freude meiner hochkrempelte
seit dem tag der episode das bewusst
sieg ohne h ja jetzt gilt's einfach sehr
verschiedene themen bergarbeiter und
beschluss freut ich sehr gerne mit regen
als bundesrat nie moment wo sie ihren
saft tropfen verunsichert worden sind
ich glaube ich habe ja meine kollegen
verunsichert will für sieben ihr
komisches wie sexy dem gremium sind sehr
schwer sagt exotisches in die werra
jetzt finden wir haben nie druck sieht
und sagt jetzt so frage ich sie jetzt so
viel sehr traurig wenn sie welk will sie
wie sie jüdischer herkunft die schotter
viel selber was ist komisch als derart
dem weser wo man dazu unbedingt sofort
versteht
alt bundesrätin ruth metzler
wir treffen sie in appenzell bei einer
freundin zu hause
die damals jüngste bundesrätin ist heute
54 jahre alt
die beiden formen kennen sich seit 1996
drei fonds ist an der landsgemeinde
dabei als der politische aufstieg von
ruth metzler beginnt an der
landsgemeinde in appenzell wird die 32
jährige als erste frau in die innere
oder regierung gewählt zwei jahre später
wird sie von der cvp für den bundesrat
nominiert
gewählt ist mit 126 stimmen frau an sich
war
[Applaus]
ich hoffe sie verstehen dass ich etwas
überwältigt von diesem ereignis
ich freue mich ich hoffe dass ich das
vertrauen das in mich gesetzt wird auch
erfüllen kann ich weiß sie hat nicht
immer einfach sein wenn die druck danke
an der ruhr gehört 430 jahre gelingt
dank joker bin ich wirklich da bin ich
wirklich sehr selbstbewusster und
sicherer und aber vermutlich eher ich
habe mir das in der sache selbst ich
habe mir das politische sache plate und
sicher mehr für weniger gedanken gemacht
was das medial für mich bedeutet das bin
ich mir sicher nicht im moment
studiert
eine große freude sie wurde zweite frau
auch ich will den mini kollege zu
kollege sie das frauchen nicht sehr
verschieden sind und es gibt die frau
nicht dahinter sehr sehr gut sehr gut
verstanden
eine linke und eine bürgerliche
beide kämpfen aktiv für die
mutterschaftsversicherung eine
verfassungsbestimmung seit ende des
zweiten weltkriegs doch die männer im
bundesrat haben sie nie umgesetzt
schlimmste argument ihnen europäische
maxi im grund nur in j frauen
der hype liebe pasta und das ist der
grund ihnen auge vor allem eine
gescheiterte versuch wie zuvor auch die
beiden frauen scheitern der bahn nach
einer niederlage okay zum tiger bekenne
man das verdauen und am ende immer
wieder war als sach- und papiere zu 22
oder drittes mal ob er viermal hiess es
denn einmal läuft ja man hat ja wirklich
noch mit ruth metzler hinweg leitet das
wenn der abstimmung
der fällt nicht sie sofort wieder ein
anderer vorschlag gemacht
gemein ist dass sie jetzt ist es da im
jahr 2004 stimmt das schweizer volk
schließlich zu 14 wochen lang erhalten
nun die mütter 80 prozent ihres letzten
lohnes zurück zur elisabeth kopp
sonnig
damals war der bundesrat ein reines
männer gremium sein dass die männlichen
mitglieder des bundesrates sie mit
freude und rückhaltlos aufnehmen und
auch integrieren
elisabeth kopp eine ausnahmeerscheinung
sie startet früh eine politische
karriere und der freisinnigen
politikerin gelingt was anderen frauen
lange verwehrt bleibt
sie wird von einem öffentlichen amt ins
andere gewählt überall seiner gremien
ist und die einzige frau auf 72 prozent
aus gemeinsam die leiter weg im
bildungsrat und so schoss im bundesrat
[Applaus]
dafür ist frau bundesrätin elisabeth
kopp im bundesrat setzt sie sich als
erstes für ein neues bier riecht ein
partnerschaft statt paar schatten das
ist das motto der eherechts revision das
neue eherecht deshalb aus ehe und
familienfeindlich zu bezeichnen ist
ebenso absurd wie die behauptung
demokratie sei staatsfeindlich handelt
besteht oft angst sich neue eherecht bis
zum prozess ein bisschen jura jeder
norbert unter wachse und orthopäde war
unsere musik die wir dürfen wie im büro
für sie sich sie die gleichberechtigung
von frauen machen ja serie
das ist das a und o vorstellen haben
sogar schnell und es laut maschine
jeweiligen absurd oder der wahrheit der
wohnsitz wettstreit frau hat mich als
ich verständnis habe wenn sie getroffen
dann sind doch einfach
ungeheuerlichkeiten warum sind sie so
sensibilisiert auf dem xi
gerechtigkeitsgründen das
gleichberechtigte
selbst einzelne sachen eigentlich hatte
der rechte noch ich bin zwar nicht fürs
gymnasium
was sie eigentlich an alitalia und
verloren israel trug ich ein ereignet
ich mache mir nur ein kurzer weg ist
heute die ich mal hier herunter platz
geschaffen für thun
dagegen fordert okay ich hab meine
prioritäten anders gesetzt
elisabeth krupp die preisgekrönte
eiskunstläuferin
[Musik]
trotzdem schließt sie ihr jus studium
mit der höchstnote summa cum laude ab
mit elisabeth kopf haben nun die frau im
bundesrat eine stimme doch sie bleiben
in der minderheit
als bundesrätin erntet sie auf kritik
[Musik]
sie gilt als hardliner rinn und
polarisiert mit einer restriktiven
asylpolitik der bundesrats- und alle an
diesen entscheiden mit beteiligten
empfinden nicht weniger menschlichkeit
aus sie aber im gegensatz zu ihnen
tragen wir auch langfristig die
verantwortung auch ruth metzler wird mit
der asylfrage konfrontiert
ihr amtsantritt fällt mitten in die
kosovo-krise 50.000 menschen flüchten in
die schweiz
sie werden vorübergehend aufgenommen und
sollen nach kriegsende wieder zurück
ruth metzler informiert sich vor ort
möglich dass die zwangsjacke linke
nationalrätin werfen ihr vor sie würde
die humanitäre tradition der schweiz
verletzen
die heftige ablehnung überrascht die
junge bundesrätin und trifft sie mehr
erwartet dass sie den themen eher sozial
eher links ist und wenn sie denn da
bitte ich dann ist gerichte die frau
dass mein kirche vor 20 jahren schon ob
es eine andere situation als behütet
elisabeth kopp ist seit vier jahren im
bundesrat
als sich die ereignisse überstürzen eine
schlagzeile jagt die andere
es geht um ihren mann sie soll
insiderwissen an ihn weitergegeben haben
um ihn zu warnen vor einem drohenden
verfahren wegen geldwäscherei
es ist so bestätigt sie was für mich
schwer nachvollziehbar
die aufwändige bundes wird die
handschließen mit marken
sie haben mich gut kennen dass sie
überhaupt auf die idee hosen gemacht zum
verhängnis wird ihr dass sie einen
telefonanruf an ihren mann zunächst
leugnete aber ich höre schlecht größter
traum ist ein letztes mal hat das
holzstock ist und das heißt einfach der
funke war der druck wird zu groß
elisabeth kopp gibt ihren rücktritt
bekannt
die verdächtigungen und unterstellungen
nicht allein gegen meine familie sondern
jetzt auch gegen mich selbst haben
zunehmend einen grad und eine dimension
erreicht die untragbar sind
[Musik]
am 12 januar 1989 verlässt elisabeth
kopf das bundeshaus
[Musik]
die erste bundesrätin öffentlich
gedemütigt und zerstört
[Musik]
sind sie das kalt
granitzka xvi ich sage ich habe nichts
gemacht
kein wunder passiert mit
[Musik]
nach vier jahren als bundesrätin wird
ruth metzler abgewählt
[Applaus]
ohne hausmacht dog stand in der eigenen
partei ja in einem gewissen sinn hätten
sie über bord geworfen
womit funde in der partei zwei cvp das
ist jetzt geschichte
und dass sie schon fair gewählt ist mit
121 stimmen
luek sda der nationalrat fristlos
[Applaus]
ich habe immer gewusst es gibt ein leben
nach dem bundesrat dass es bereits jetzt
beginnt hätte ich mir anders gewünscht
wieder gibt es proteste
bei ihrer abwahl sagt ruth metzler heute
waren damals auch die frauen mit
entscheidend und ich freue mich
unterstützt
[Musik]
die gleiche sein
ich hatte das gefühl mit dem publikum
auf eine andere weise kommunizieren zu
können
weitab der politik auf eine viel
persönlichere emotionale rede
die musik gehörte immer zu meinem leben
meine erste musikalische erinnerung ist
die blasmusik an den fronleichnam feiern
oder am ersten august und das
eidgenössische turnfest da war ich bei
den jungen turnerinnen wir üben auf
einem großen fußballfeld eingerannt von
glas muslim calmy rey ist die vierte
frau im bundesrat
ich bringe meine wurzeln meine welcher
kultur mein leben als mutter und
großmutter und mein engagement für die
sozial benachteiligten mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
na was wird sich ändern im bundesrat
wenn jetzt eine großmutter ist was
werden sie einbringen
das ist nicht so lachen weil die frauen
die die kinder haben die haben eine sehr
schwere leben
die arbeiten die haben kinder zu
erziehen und sie haben nicht das es gibt
nicht genug plätze um die kinder zu
verhüten das ist ein richtiges problem
das ist ein schweres leben und manchmal
finanzielles ist auch schwer
das bringt es auch mit ich aber dieses
leben gekannt und meine tochter kennt
sind die erinnerungen die ich habe ist
ihr schreibtisch stehen die bitte der
wohnung stand meine mutter wurde präsent
sein
ich konnte die dinger nicht einfach
laufen lassen
ich glaube das habe ich auch geerbt in
guten oder schlechten die arbeit das ist
wahr das ist ein wert den du uns
vermittelt hast gab es streit
konfrontation ja sie ist sehr autoritär
ich habe damit leben gelernt sie
scheinen auch autoritär zu sein
ich hoffe nicht so sehr mein maßstab ist
wenn meine töchter sagen mach es nicht
so die großmutter der frage wo es im
zentrum stadtladen er raubt und die
große politik machten hofer schlagzeilen
im jahr 2008 trägt sie bei einem empfang
durch den iranischen präsidenten ein
kopftuch
[Musik]
ein unnötiger kniefall heißt es
sehen sie dass es viel leichter zu hause
zu bleiben in einem sessel zu sitzen und
zu kritisieren es ist viel schwieriger
dort zu gehen und zu sagen augen in
augen hören sie mal herr präsident das
ist nicht akzeptabel dass sie die
existenzrecht israel verleugnen
es ist ein kleiner schritt
[Musik]
ich bin sehr glücklich diese diskussion
beginnen zu können
es kann nicht sein dass die alte
traditionelle neutralitätspolitik durch
den aktivismus einmal den träger dann
bei anderen es gibt keine außenpolitik
von kanal
es gibt eine aussenpolitik der schweiz
und die aussenpolitik der schweiz ist
umgesetzt vom bundesrat vom 11 sie haben
einen charakter einen eher starken
charakter wird truppe gehirns das ist ob
er eine qualität wenn man in einer
regierung sitzt
[Musik]
im jahr 2007
eveline widmer schlumpf steht vor einer
großen entscheidung
sie ist als bundesrätin gewählt
christoph blocher abgewählt wird sie ja
sagen wird sie die wahl akzeptieren
[Musik]
die ganze schweiz wartet gespannt
phz
dass sie ja sagen so 88 prozent es wäre
dass sie aus und das parlament das dabei
aber der gute rost
sie haben geschätzte damen und herren
wir mit dieser wahl gästen geschätzte
damen und herren
wenn die diesen zahlen
franken
auch immer wieder unterschiedliche
meinungen haben so lassen sie uns doch
eine ahnung stets mit respekt und
toleranz begegnen in diesem sinne
erkläre ich anna material
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist für mich schon noch schwer diese
bohrung also der vorwurf ich hätte ich
hätte die parteileitung ich hätte das
volk ich weiß nicht ich hätte alle
angelogen dass das trifft
[Musik]
vor wenigen wochen eveline widmer
schlumpf erzählt weshalb sie in die
politik einstieg
mir ist es zum ersten mal richtig
bewusst wurde 1970 wie die 15-jährige
gymnasial stellen an denen verordnung
niedrig wer jetzt kein haus welbergen
gebe mit zwei schwestern totaler
frauenhaushalt aufgewachsen mein papa
ist sogar runde schließlich alles ist
also für mich die diskussion bis nico
und ich bin auf der straße und haben mit
entsetzen plakat was kaiser männer
bewahrt uns vor dem frauenstimmrecht man
trifft der schlag
dementsprechend braucht sie haben große
gruppe vertrag sehe vor verschiedenen
frauenorganisationen auch politisch vor
ordner steckt er frauen und dank sehr
wie der vorherige stande sind und dass
wir spaß gemacht und der politik zu das
wäre die eigentlich dem euro einfach für
die natürlichkeit alles im griff
gemalte für die der vorschrift macht er
das nur druck macht wählen
nur drei monate noch viel mehr
aufgestellt das können sie sich
vorstellen nach der abstimmung
in der innen- oder kassel die
rechtlichen grundlagen himmel und
setzten die frauen selber dafür sorgen
dass das die nach oben gesetzt wird und
das hat
1971 die ersten frauen im parlament so
sima
[Musik]
wie lang und lilian uchtenhagen vor
wenigen tagen
doris leuthard posiert mit frauen der
allianz es für ein gruppenfoto
für bundesrätin leuthard war die cvp
nationalrätin josie meyer wichtig
die juristin und ebenso wie nie motegi
totaler sprach ich frau ärgerlich für
die generation und die hätten extrem für
ihre sparte arbeitet einfach wie sie
hätte können argumentieren und einem
ohne sieg dastehen da stimmt nicht dass
fonds und etf die debatte und ich klicke
dich mit deiner den abermals bier
trinken wird gefährlich sind da hätten
wir immer druck gemacht der solo umgang
eigentlich dazu führt respektiert ist es
auch es klagt bild caroline aber in
extremo mitmachen und sichert ihr taxi
mit dem spruch oder frau ist bundes und
das ist für mich also blieben sie das
klare ja eigentlich einen urknall für
musste mario sagen ich schwöre hören sie
einfach auf mitmenschen kümmern sie sich
um die echten zahlen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nicht kandidiert haben für den bundesrat
ist ja auch dass frauen da fragt man
sich immer sofort das mit grund club
obere zeit rund 1000 zu fassen um raum
und ich mich bis heute immer wieder muss
er sagen okay ihr wirklich dass
vorarlberg medien sind da sehr schnell
gerade bei guter paraden tag der
emotionen zeigten
ich bin relativ nah am wasser gebaut
wurden dass sofort probleme traut ihr
präsident den senioren hof geboren und
sie hätte emotionen das inzwischen fast
fertig sehen wir zum teil sehr
selbstkritisch mit sich selber und diese
fähigkeiten reduzieren stadtteil
therapieren und sagen okay ich möchte
mir das tun sofern ich hatte ja immer
wieder kam
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und ich habe mich mit frau nicht aus
zu sehen ist also ich glaube der
bezirksregierung juristen sind wieso er
seit 2000 nicht könne und mit und aus
einem bundesrat gegangen ist wirklich
druck für mich selber ist das ist nicht
groß
[Musik]
dass sie immer noch viele das ist sie
besser sie so dass erstklässler zentrum
peter frey war schon immer noch bis der
vergangenheit und und unter druck dass
sie eine ganz willkommen sind
es ist das wirklich vor der tür und
sagte ja genau aber absolut genau wie
gerecht werden mag
und die muss wirklich nicht noch
zusätzlich bringen enterprise für männer
und für frauen sagte sie wenn man
prozent frauen für frauen zu laut
standard regierung bundesrat stagnation
und gerade unter wirtschaft haben ihr
eigenes gefühl kann ok mehr als
doppelspieler die frauen blieb sogar
mehr als 50 prozent also mit
akademischen ausbildungen und trotzdem
überall in die obere management kommt am
stärksten ist eigentlich fast immer
lauter der großen technischen bewegung
viele senioren und physiker und
naturwissenschaften und ganz wenig
frauen und darum habe ich eigentlich
immer versucht die möglichkeit im
redefluss mitzumachen und frauen zu
unterstützen ihre laufbahn
wir haben heute diverse maßnahmen
eingeleitet alle unserem apartment für
unsere 2600 mitarbeiter
das ist der telearbeit das ist mir mehr
teilzeit beschäftigungsmodelle
flexiblere familienfreundliche
arbeitszeitmodelle aber auch den
vaterschaftsurlaub mit fünf tagen werden
hier bei uns einführen
simonetta sommaruga die siebte
bundesrätin
für mich eine ganz wichtige und
klavierunterricht habe ich nach tripolis
verschleppt die freilich auch das
bedürfnis kann einen anderen teil von
den moderatoren von abano
und 18 und als ich das sehr von der
situation von der frau mit totaler
abhängigkeit nimmt größte ikk classic
ketchup kliniken.de aussichtslos das hat
mich schon sehr politisiert und vor
allem als ich wollte mich für die dauer
ich setze die partei politische
beschlüsse machen
frau simonetta sommaruga
[Applaus]
sie könnte für blüte im land das auch
die ermäßigung lady der jungen mutter
helvetia belastet sie das vielleicht
nicht wirklich etwas mehr über meter
letzten wochen geschrieben hätte das ist
eigentlich lustig sie manch amüsante
männliche bizarr aber ich glaube mit dem
muss man als epigone anderem ohne
toilette neue titel hat mit ihrer wahl
stellen die frauen das erste mal die
mehrheit im bundesrat
[Musik]
beim thema atomstrom wird das
entscheidend sein denn aus der atomstrom
befürworterin doris leuthard wird nach
der fukushima-katastrophe eine andere
energie politikerin
und deshalb ist der bundesrat überzeugt
dass das szenario 2 also ein
schrittweiser ausstieg aus der
kernenergie
der wichtige schritt ist für die zukunft
und deshalb denke ich ist das durchaus
auch ein historischer tag aus
wattenscheid erhöht kraska frauen mit qi
und so schwer wenn sie natürlich gerade
als bundesrat im kollegium mehrheit an
das handliche ganze wieder zurück ins
büro
[Musik]
das war um das rathaus immer gefunden
hat egal aus welcher partei muss wo man
sich merken das richtig dass mit krömer
dieses amt nutzer zu möglich neue wagen
oder einen entscheid fällen wo man was
will ich mit widerstands lachen aber wir
jetzt gemacht will sie das auch richtig
das parlament hingegen ist von einer
frauenmehrheit weit weit entfernt
[Musik]
bei frauenanliegen spürt dass simonetta
sommaruga
diskriminierung hat sie als junge frau
selber erfahren weniger auf hälfte aus
wie vorgang verlieren kann ich
allerdings erst spät im grunde habe ich
nach der cup wird seit längerem
verhandelt aber im klassischen fall bei
den new york sehe ich habe dank tja ich
muss die arbeit gut mache ich muss jetzt
bewiesen dass ich das überhaupt eine
veranstaltung und die ehefrauen anliegen
thematisiert werden
simonetta sommaruga ist als referentin
eingeladen
sie wird hier als schlüsselfigur
wahrgenommen
auch wegen ihres engagements für
lohngleichheit im parlament
[Musik]
wenn eine frau
die gleiche ausbildung haben gleich lang
im unternehmen ist
den gleichen job macht und auch noch auf
der gleichen karte stufe stehen dann
soll sie gleich viel lohn erhalten und
zwar unabhängig davon ob sie früher
einmal drei oder vier jahre ausgesetzt
hat weil sie kinder bekommen haben löhne
einfach eins zu eins vergleich zu
vergleichen gestaubt sich in der praxis
auf sehr schwierig hier wird einmal mehr
regulierend in den liberalen
arbeitsmarkt eingegriffen aus diesem
grund empfiehlt ihnen die svp fraktion
heute auf diese vorlage gar nicht erst
anzutreten
wir sprechen hier von einem
verfassungsauftrag und nicht von einem
wunsch zusammengefasst ist somit klar
festzuhalten dass diese lohn analysen
zwar gut gemeint sein mag durchaus der
zusätzlichen regulierungen für die
wirtschaft nichts bringt einen tag
aufwand alle vier jahre meine damen und
herren um ein verfassungsmäßiges recht
auf lohngleichheit einzulösen
nach 37 jahren ist das zu viel verlangt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
revolution die vorlauf aber der es ist
quasi wirkt weil wenn die große firmen
auf vier jahre die analyse macht hat man
sie diskriminierung ihre firma denn ich
das schon bisher besuchs los weil er das
hört der schweiz frauen immer noch
weniger verdienen als männer genommen
weil seine frau sind wie es kommt als
ich in den bundesrat gewählt wurde waren
wir vier frauen eine frauenmehrheit
diese für schweizer verhältnisse
verrückte zeit dauerte 14 monaten
dann war es vorbei heute sind wir zwei
und viele finden zwei sei doch
eigentlich genug
[Musik]
aber es muss doch eigentlich wenn man
gesehen dass es sieben verschiedene
kantonsregierungen kantonsgericht frauen
karin des lotsen abteilungs oder und ab
219 leider haben es heute geschafft und
ich sage erstaunlich alle voten
fortschritt mindestens vorübergehend
zurück
vor allem auf wirtschaftlich nur nicht
nur politik und in gang gesetzt haben
vielleicht noch vor fünf jahren
wirklichkeit als heute lag also ist
dafür braucht nicht mehr passiert wird
das nur ein oder zwei und drei die
wörter nicht passiert also das wirklich
für sich und ihre geschichte dass sie
krachend könnte es den anderen frau
überhaupt empfehlen den ex co ich würde
sagen es sei gut wenn sie die politik
gehen wir einfach nötig ist es geht
einfach eine andere politik unbedingt
mit mir brauchen frauen was sie möchte
wie sie warnt gesellschaft vom boden für
andere und wenn mir das nur den anderen
übernommen
so prägt wie mir endlich man sich das
vorstellen gebunden software sehr
einfach es liegt in der hand der helfer
der bundesversammlung als lüge dass es
immer drei sorten und vier verdoppelt
unser land hat in sachen gleichstellung
jahrzehnte lange verspätung
wir müssen täglich einfordern das macht
und verantwortung zwischen frauen und
männern gerecht verteilt wird wir sind
noch lange nicht am ziel
danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]